this is brutally honest advice to my
younger less confident self having an
epic story is about asking the girl it's
about shooting the shot it's about
launching the business about running the
ad about knocking on the door quitting
the job taking the risk when you're 85
years old and on your deathbed you're
not going to wish you had fewer crazy
stories you're going to wish you had
taken more shots don't build confidence
build evidence confidence comes as a
result of evidence not the other way
around confidence without evidence is a
delusion it's you beating your chest
looking at yourself in the mirror trying
to pretend you're something you're not
do it so you get the confidence but
don't think you need confidence to do it
so the whole idea of fake it until you
make it should switch to walk it before
you talk it right prove it to yourself
so you don't need to prove it to other
people and let your path that you're
talking for you until you win effort
always goes unnoticed get used to it if
you aren't willing to suck you're never
going to get good losers stay losers
because they aren't willing to lose
confidence is also domain specific so
you can be really good at public
presentations and really bad at talking
to girls it takes a lot for a skill to
transfer between domains and so if you
want to get good at the thing don't try
and do something to the left of it just
do the thing the first sales consult I
ever took I didn't close and I say that
because everyone just imagines that mosy
just came in just slinging credit cards
and stacking bodies right it didn't work
that way I came in it was a 5minute
conversation the girl was like I need to
go get my card from home and I said oh
yeah okay go do that and she walked away
and I went to my boss he's like how'd it
go I said oh I closed her and he was
like oh that's awesome he's like you got
the credit card I said oh no she's going
to come back with the card and he
literally stopped what he was doing with
six other guys around him and they all
non-stop laughed for a minute straight
like they couldn't breathe cuz they
thought how stupid what I had just said
was but I had no idea and so that was my
first ever experience in sales I'm known
for sales now and I wouldn't even say
I'm confident in sales it's just more
like this is what works and has worked
for me take it or leave it and so people
perceived that as confidence but it's
simply just based on experience and
confidence comes from experience what it
really is is a prediction what you think
is going to happen will happen and so
even in statistics what is your
confidence metric this is 78 it's
literally just what the percentage
likelihood that what you think's going
to happen is going to happen and so how
do you increase the likelihood that what
you think's going to happen is going to
happen have it have happened already I
could have either spent 30 minutes every
day looking at myself in the mirror and
telling myself I was going to be a great
sales guy or I could have reviewed the
[__] script which one do you think
would get make me a better salesperson
reviewing the script you can take all
the time that you're trying to spend
psyching yourself up and you'll feel
significantly more confident not having
done that and simply knowing what you're
going to say which you get from practice
the world belongs to those who can keep
doing without seeing the result of
they're doing and the longer you can
wait to see the result of you're doing
while still continuing to do is the
extent to which you can win big in life
for example to be a top 1% podcaster you
have to upload 21 podcasts 21 top 1% %
90% of people don't get past one 9%
don't get past 20 and then 1% of
podcasters of all of them make it to 21
plus so when people say try harder it
usually just means don't give up the
price for Excellence has never been so
low people give up so easily now that
it's just so easy to win by just being
willing to post 20 times you're in the
top 1% like am the top 1% we're not even
talking 10 top half top one % people are
so afraid of being humiliated they get
the long-term humiliation of never
amounting to anything no one's going to
watch your first 20 episodes anyways and
even if they do it doesn't matter
because that's not what you're building
towards like you posting those 20 isn't
what you judge yourself on you should be
judging yourself on the difference
between your first one and your 20th one
are you better probably and the
difference between your 20th one and
your 100th one because the win is you
you are the asset You're Building not
the downloads that you get on your first
shot mosy immediately had a podcast with
millions of downloads every single month
no I spent 4 and 1/2 years making two
podcasts a week straight didn't miss and
guess how many podcast downloads I was
getting per month at the end of that 2
to 3,000 downloads a month not a lot I
used to think to myself okay well each
one of these podcasts gets like 200
downloads well 200 downloads is like an
auditorium of people and so would I feel
okay giving a speech to 200 people yeah
and even before that when they was
getting like 10 or 15 downloads per
episode if I had a little lunch and
learn that I would I used to have to do
to like get leads for a business I'd be
fine talking to a group of 10 or 15
people because the reality is that those
people are doing me more of a favor than
I'm doing them they're literally giving
me their ears so that I can practice my
voice and how to talk and how to present
and it was only at year 4 and A2 to 5
when things started taking off and you
know what the two things that changed
are one is I did call I changed it from
gym secrets to just the game which was a
business thing so it made it more go
more people and the second thing and
here's the real one is that I sold a
company for $46 million and so people
are like oh what does this guy have to
say and the big thing that everyone
misses is people try and dissect my
content the message is 10% of how people
consume it 90% is the context around the
message so Elon muskin can tweet on the
toilet and be like I'm on the throne
taking a [__] and it'll get a million
likes why because it's Elon Musk he's
the richest man in the world and owns
three of the biggest companies that are
most Innovative of all time I don't Kid
myself and think that like my content is
so much better than other people there's
plenty of people have better content
than me that don't get the same views
and the reason is because I have the
context they don't have the proof and
solve for the proof and then the content
will take care of itself because one you
will know what you're talking about
because you have proof that you know
what you're talking about and people
will believe you which is why you should
solve for evidence above everything else
like evidence gives you the confidence
if someone says Alex I don't think you
know [__] about business I'd be like
okay it doesn't really affect me I do
know we cross 100 milon net worth at age
32 I know that but if someone said that
to you and you haven't accomplished
anything you don't have anything to
stand back on and it hurts you more but
I have proof so it's like you can just
deflect it towards the proof and keep
living your life the secret to longevity
is especially in the content game but
really in any game that you're trying to
at least help other people with is that
if you've done the thing you can be
certain rather than confident be certain
based on what you've done not based on
what you say other people should do
there used to be uh too big to fail and
I think there's an alternative which is
too good to fail if you make your stuff
so [__] good that only one person who
gets exposed to it sends it to somebody
else then you have nothing to worry
about and you will eventually get
discovered it's a Time game and in the
meanwhile you just keep getting better
which is the point because at the end of
the day you're going to die everyone's
going to forget about you anyways and so
you might as well just work on the one
asset that you get to keep for the rest
of your life which is you and rather
than measuring yourself based on how
many views he gets versus how many views
you get measure Yourself by how much
work he puts into one of his shorts
versus what you put into one of your
shorts and then you might think the
output is more reasonable and if there's
a top sales guy in your organization
who's making more money than you compare
not what his commission check is to
yours every month compare how many calls
he's making how many times you practice
the script how many calls he's made
before you how many sales he's closed
before you what time a day he shows up
at work what time of day he leaves
whether he works weekends or not whether
he's willing to hop on the phone in a
family context so he can still close the
deal if you're doing all the inputs the
mat the outputs will always match on a
long enough time Horizon and if you are
new to the game then my recommendation
is not only to match inputs but to
double or triple the inputs that someone
ahead of you is doing and the reason you
do that is because if you just match
your inputs then you're always going to
be behind them because they're already
ahead of you because they're better than
you and so if you both do the same
amount of work they're going to keep
getting better and so with you so you
have to do twice the work you got to be
like Kobe right where everyone else is
doing one practice a day you do two
practices a day and in the beginning
they'll be better than you and then
you'll match them but because you're
doing twice the work eventually you'll
get better and then that's how you win
yeah and one of the biggest misnomers in
in whatever Endeavor you're trying to
track is people track the wrong metrics
they track the lagging metrics rather
than the leading metrics lagging metrics
are what happen those are the outputs
and if you want to track those fine but
the real things to track are what you're
doing to create the outputs so I don't
want to necessarily even track sales I
want to track how many calls I'm making
if I'm trying to get in shape I'm not
necessarily going to track the weight
I'm doing I'm going to track how many
calories I'm eating and so the more ways
you measure the more ways you can win
and so the idea the ultimate win at life
is where you can shift things that out
of your control that you deem winning to
things that are under your control which
you can deem winning because if you're
measuring on whether you lost the fat or
not sometimes people take longer some
people don't that's something that you
actually can't control what you can
control are the inputs and so if you say
based on this if I do this one thing
every day for a long enough period of
time I'll eventually get there the real
winners cut out the I'll eventually get
there and say if I do this every day I
have won the thing that I try and focus
on now is the Delta between how hard I
tried and how hard I can Poss possibly
try and if I know that the gap between
those two is zero then I have one and
I've decided to spend a inordinate
amount of effort trying to make that my
definition of winning is that there's
nothing left in the tank if you get into
a harder career path or one that takes
more reps to get good at or more reps to
get into then every day you can win
based on saying like everyone else does
100 I do 250 and I have nothing left to
give I won and that should satisfy you
and if you're if you're obsessive on the
external thing that takes too long and
you will give up too soon one of the
things that took me too long to learn
was the difference between the finite
and infinite frame and so finite frame
is where you have known players agreed
upon rules and a way to win or lose at
the end and then the game is over an
infinite frame you have known and
unknown players no agreed upon rules and
the point of the game is to keep the
game going and all the greatest games
that I've ever participated in marriage
Health business you don't win at
marriage the point is to stay married
you don't win at Health the point is to
stay in shape you don't win at business
the point is to stay in business and so
by default if you don't give up you win
and so that's the big frame shift which
is why leaving everything on the field
is the way you have to Define winning if
you want to win in the long term and
anything worth doing takes great time if
you stick with it and you make that the
win you'll notice that the external win
will just happen on its own and if you
really commit to that perspective it
won't even mean much to you because if
you make that everything it's the same
thing with the guys who win the golds
and then kill themselves or win the
championship and then go into these
massive depressions is because they're
playing the wrong game when Kobe was
asked shortly before he died like do you
think that you're somebody who's afraid
of losing or do you think you're
somebody who loves winning he basically
denied both frames he said I'm
paraphrasing I just love playing to the
best of my ability and that's what he
measures himself off of the fact that
the world chooses to measure him on the
fact that he's won so many games that's
the world's problem not ours it's saying
I'm game master not a player and I
choose to play by these rules and as
long as I playing I win by default and
it's because I'm not accepting the
world's rules for winning I make my own
an easier analogy here is and this is a
naval Ron quote he said what looks like
work to other people should feel like
play for you if you look at an artist
and he's painting you're like hey how
soon are you going to finish that
painting the point for the artist is to
paint he'll finish that piece and he'll
start the next one but the process of
painting is the thing that they enjoy
and so the idea is that if you can
commit and the broader you can
generalize what you're committing to the
easier it will be to stick with it so
you might be like I love making calls
but I hate entering things in the CRM
well both of those are required for the
role of sales and so I prefer to chunk
up a level and say I prefer to do hard
work because of what that work does to
me then whether I'm putting [__] into
the CRM or editing a document or having
a hard conversation all of those things
are difficult and I see those as all
contributing to the person I ultimately
want to be until eventually I die and it
won't matter anyways and so the only
asset that you really get to keep with
you is your character and that's the
only thing you keep building and so if
you make the character the W at the end
of the day did or I did I not contribute
to the character of the person that I
want to become if that's the W every day
you can never lose if you have your menu
option of things that you can do in life
just remove quitting as one of them and
then try your next idea and if you are
in that Rocky cut scene and you're 2
months in 3 months in remember that the
rocky cut scene in the movie last a
couple seconds and the rocky cut scene
in real life might last a few years and
so whenever I get to a low point where I
think why do I even bother doing this I
just like to remind myself this is where
most people stop and this is why they
don't win and as hard as this is going
to sound the best thing that I ever did
was not listen to other people's
opinions about my life they don't want
the best version of you they want the
version of you who best serves them and
unfortunately the closer people are to
you the more similarly they they'll see
themselves in you and the more your
success will make them feel bad about
themselves and I can promise you this
from somebody who might be a little
further I have more people who root for
me now that I've already won than people
who rooted for me along the way no one
is doing as well as you think they're
doing so by comparison everyone is
better off than they think because the
cumulative median visually is probably
three times higher than what the actual
median is and so if you're like oh I'm
average or slightly below average
compared to the perceived median of
society you're probably way above
average and that's okay and being above
or below average doesn't even matter
anyways because you've got a lot of
innings left there's a lot of quarters
left to play and so like until the day
you die you still have hope you still
have a chance you can still keep moving
forward whenever someone gives you your
their opinion about what you should do
with their your life it's really them
saying this is my preference of how I
want to live my life and I say great
live your life that way and I'll live my
life this way because me living my my
life has no effect on you so live your
life the way you want to live it and I
don't want your life either they State
make those statements because they feel
uncomfortable and so they have to like
release it and so they say that to you
to make themselves feel better and
that's their problem not yours I think
I've learned a lot of frames around not
caring about others people's opinions be
out of necessity because I was so
crippled by the opinions of other people
for what felt like such a long time that
I always had to face my death in order
to get myself to move and so I talk
about death a lot because it has
actually been one of the few things that
actually motivates me to change my
behavior and so when I had done all the
things that I thought would impress
other people one I realized that they
didn't really care and secondly I
realized that I deeply cared about how
much I hated my life when I was like is
this what winning feels like because if
this is what winning is then I don't
want to play by thinking I'd rather be
dead than continue to play this game I
was forced to change the game I was
playing which is like well what is a
game that I would like to win at well
I'd like to win a game that is by rules
that I set out and there are things that
I can control and then those people
because you break their mold of what
they're supposed to be doing and they
might be miserable too but they are not
willing to take the risk that you're
willing to take because they care about
other people's opinions more than you do
because they haven't gone through that
little journey that you just went
through fine you do it your way they do
it their way I mean I went from prodigal
son my father super proud of me
graduating Vanderbilt in three years
president the fraternity vice president
of the powerlifting Team Management
Consultant to uh minimum wage employee
like that's a pretty significant Dro in
status I have these frames because
people will say whatever they want but
for me that relative drop in status was
a lot I went from about as high status
as you can get in a as a 22-year-old to
about as low status as you can get I
mean I remember having people be like so
did you go to college and I was like
yeah I went to college and I [__]
murdered it and I did everything and the
cuz the implied question is why are you
here and so that's what in the beginning
hurt a ton but then I just realized that
they just didn't know and they were were
asking genuinely and all of my judgment
around that was just my own problem how
I'm perceiving this question is
affecting my mood to such a great degree
what if I applied this to every question
all these people are asking me things
and I'm either getting offended or
getting complimented but the statement
doesn't change so that sounds like a me
problem and so the more I started diving
into things like that the less bothered
I became by everyone everyone else's
opinion because they also have no
context even if they did mean it is an
insult so what if they're saying well
I'm better than you I'd be like yes you
are a lot of even successful people
frame their success around trying to
prove someone wrong right but when you
try and create your entire existence in
opposition to someone you actually give
them complete control over your life it
means that because of the things that
this person has said I will choose to
change all of my behavior which
basically means that the directives from
that person have commanded you to do
whatever you do and if you like to be a
free person and want to be somebody who
acts of their own valtion then I choose
to accept insults so that I can live my
life rather than living in contrast to
them and giving my control to the person
who insulted me I that would mean I put
me changing your mind above my goals
which I don't do my goals are more
important to me than changing your mind
I'm super sensitive to I am statements
labeling statements like this like I'm a
neat freak I'm the type of person who so
whenever you're dating someone you're
getting to know someone people like to
blanket I am statements really early on
to set the stage like I'm this type I'm
the type person who likes to show up
early I like to clean things I'm a
labeler I'm a whatever and then and this
is the Insidious part they then say
because
and then they insert a reason that they
made up or that sounded good in the past
and people nodded their heads and agreed
with because my mom never loved me
enough because I didn't get enough hugs
because I gave a speech once and
everyone laughed at me because you don't
know and the reality is you will never
know all we know is that you do a
certain type of behavior that's it by
giving these because statements all this
power you actually put all the power
into something that is unchangeable in
the past and so you have to keep dealing
with it whereas if you just said I do
these things period now if I want to
change what I do then I should just
reward myself in the present for doing
something different and that makes it a
lot more valuable and it makes your
identity and what you do as a result or
rather what you do and your identity as
a result something under your control
you don't want to blame the things in
the past that you can't change you want
to blame things in the present that you
can't so if you said I have trouble
getting close to girls because my mom
and I aren't close one you give your
mother all the power in your love life
you give power to something that
happened in the past that you can't
change to things that are happening in
the present that you can change and so
wouldn't it be more useful to say in the
past I have struggle to get close to
girls period now that could be for a
number of reasons thing is is that you
don't know what reason it is cuz I could
say let's say imagine all these things
happening you struggled with your mom
let's say you had a bad breakup at some
point in your life you're not in shape I
could say I struggle getting close to
girls and I could use any of those three
as my reasons but which of those serve
me none of them all we know is that you
struggle to get close to girls okay well
then just look at what it would take to
get close to girls and then do that
rather than having this other thing
that's attached to the behavior that you
can't do anything about it just makes
changing who you are and what you do a
lot easier sometimes people are such
douchebags they will tell a young child
you will never have a successful
relationship with a woman because you
don't respect or love me a mother or the
reverse could be true of a father
they're a [__] douchebag for saying
that because they are labeling you with
something that you can't change but
that's their problem it also is no basis
in fact when people are like look at how
the son treats the mother that's how
he's going to treat his wife why the
[__] would I treat my wife like I treat
my mother dear God that's just a
statement that sounds good but has no
basis in fact you treat your wife like
you treat your wife you treat your
mother like you treat your mother
they're different people people want to
have problems because it gives them a
reason to suck and it be okay it gives
them ego padding so they can protect
themselves for the reason why they're
not successful for the reason they
haven't accomplished what they said they
were going to accomplish and so they
lean on their potential comma and their
trauma as the two reasons that people
prop up I've got lots of potential but I
have all this trauma and neither of
those matter I've gone through three
stages of like mental development in
terms of how I see changing my behavior
in the beginning I attributed my
behavior to my past traumas the second
phase was that I I chose to change the
story what if my mother was just trying
to feel better it wasn't my fault so
then I changed my behavior in that sense
the third phase which is where I'm at
now maybe it'll be a fourth phase but
the third phase was I behave this way
period the because statement in the
second half is completely irrelevant one
because I don't know it two because I
can't change it so I might as well just
choose to do the thing that I want to do
irrelevant of my past the single
strongest predictor of my behavior is
what will make the more epic story I've
thought about that frame a lot and it's
still continued to win out and so when
I'm forced to make a decision between
two things I prefer to choose the one
that's the more epic story because
either you have an epic story of failure
or you have an epic story of success but
no 85-year olds are regretting their
epic stories they are regretting the
stories they never told our minds are
meaning making machines and they have to
be because they create associations
between things we know and things we
don't know that's how we learn the
problem is that our brains will make
wrong associations and then they will
plague us for the rest of our lives but
we can just redefine what the
association means for ourselves to make
our lives easier because whether you
miss the game-winning shot when there's
a huge crowd or you miss it when no one
else is there the only reason it h hurts
more is because you choose to let it
hurt you more now there are things that
you can do prior to the game-winning
shot that can increase the likely that
you make it which is that you practice
way more in high stakes conditions over
and over and over again and if you do
that it increases the likelihood your
confidence that you'll be able to make
it why because you've made them before
and if you're like well I missed my
first ever game-winning shot now what do
I do well you practice in every other
condition that's as close to that as you
can until eventually you make one and
then when you do make one you'll have
evidence that you've made one and you
try and make one again what you probably
don't know is that Michael Jordan has
missed more game-winning shots than he
has made but he's remembered for the
ones that he made but how was he able to
make them by missing and being willing
to shoot again on that basis of story
The many excuses that we give ourselves
in Reverse can make a more epic story
and so rather than to say like these are
all the reasons that I can't succeed I
think reframing that is these are all
the reasons that when I succeed it'll be
an even better story and it'll be more
inspiring to other people is a much more
powerful frame the more disadvantages
you have when you start the more epic
story you have when you win Donald
Miller has one of the most powerful
frames of heroes and villains I've ever
heard of heroes and villains always have
the same backstory it's pain they're
always an orphan right or the the
villain has some sort of disfigurement
to show that they went through hard
times the difference is what the
character chooses to do about it
villains say the world hurt me I'm going
to hurt it back Heroes say the world
hurt me I'm not going to let anyone else
hurt this way so Heroes use pain
villains are used by it and so I think
all of us have the choice to become our
own Heroes our own villains in our own
life simply by how we choose to do with
the pain that we all inevitably
experience so pain is a constant the
choice about how we react to it is the
thing that dictates the path of Our
Lives you know there there are certain
rules of playing the game that have
served me really well one of them is and
that's okay and I probably use that
frame more than anything else which is
I'm not close with XYZ relative your
parent your mom your sister your brother
and that's okay it's been a a lot of my
mental effort trying to untangle stories
that I told in the past about things
that were my fault or were a problem and
the easiest way that I found to solve
problems is to decide they're not
problems to begin with I have a handful
of pictures that I took for the first 5
years of sucking during business and I
use those pictures all the time every
day and the zillions of pictures after I
became successful I barely use any of
them the time to document your life is
when it sucks not when it's great
because those are the stories that
you're going to tell and those are going
to be the reminders that you use in the
present day of things that you have been
through and prove as to who you really
are because my favorite line in The
Matrix is in the second or third Matrix
when Morpheus is standing on the hell
and he's looking at towards everyone and
he said I stand Here truthfully unafraid
not because of the path that lies before
me but because of the path that lies
behind me and so the struggle period
that you may be in right now is the path
behind your future self that you are
building so that that man or that woman
can stand on the pulpit and look at you
straight dead in the eyes in the mirror
and say I'm confident and I stand
truthfully here unafraid not because of
what I said my goal is going to be but
because what I've been through to get
here and so here's my advice to my
younger self document your life more
otherwise you'll forget the details and
the details are what make it worth
remembering it's the times you're
sleeping on the floor it's the time the
person walks out and you miss the
seventh sale that day it's the time when
your bank account's at its absolute
lowest it's when you're car breaks down
on the side of the road and you're like
what am I going to do now I can barely
afford this right those are the moments
the ones that you want to ignore the
ones that you want to look away from
that are the ones that you need to
capture because those are the moments
that you will tell in the future of
things you got through because no heroes
are heroes without Epic monsters and the
bigger the monster the greater the hero